what to expect with the ethereum merge
those who follow the crypto space
closely will know there is a huge change
coming for ethereum blockchain which is
the technology behind the second largest
cryptocurrency by market cap
we've been waiting for this upgrade for
years this change known as the merge is
a software upgrade it's ethereum's
transition from proof of work to proof
of stake
so what does emerge mean for users
developers are reassuring the impacts
will be minimal but the upgrade will
allow ethereum developers to introduce
new features
this update will see the ethereum
mainnet combined with the beacon chain
which is a proof-of-stake system and is
expected to be more eco-friendly by
minimizing the environmental impact of
mining activities
many nfts are built on the ethereum
network the transition is expected to
reduce energy consumption meaning users
will be able to mint and sell nfts in a
more sustainable way for more updates on
the merge and crypto content follow us
on quick take